hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm answering
a question from one of our YouTube
viewers awesome love you guys
this one is coming from Gabe who wrote
insane I have an idea on how I can set a
cosmetic line with no with little
capital where the problem is how can I
get valued customers continually buy my
products can you help with some insight
thanks for the question Gabe awesome
question I think you've if you found a
way to get it started with little
capital that's that's one of the biggest
challenges a lot of entrepreneurs are
facing how to bootstrap their business
from the start I think really the thing
here is making sure that you have a
really good product and just get it in
front of your customers you're in a
great type of business where with
cosmetics
it's a consumable product so people are
going to use it up and they're going to
want to buy some more if it's good right
so some business is a lot harder you
know if you look at real estate for
example how often are you buying a house
you know every X number of years so it's
hard to maintain that relationship in
between but for something like cosmetics
they use up your sample they use up your
first product then they're going to
hopefully want to buy more so that's
it's a great way to be able to get
people to keep coming back so start with
having a really valuable product so I
don't know what type of cosmetics you're
selling but it doesn't matter so much as
long as it is really helpful to your
audience and really explain the benefits
to them and show them how they can how
they can make repeat purchases so if you
have a location or if it's online or if
they just have to call you whatever it
is make it easy for them to want to buy
but your your main first step is just
getting in front of them and getting
them to try if it's an awesome product
then they'll use it and if they keep
using and they like it they're going to
come back and want to buy it from you
so sampling is a great way to do it even
in other industries if you look at mrs.
Fields Cookies Debi fields when she was
promoting her business her cookie
business she always brought samples with
her so people could try it again they
eat it they consume it and then they
want to buy smart cuz they really loved
it and so they keep coming back so the
biggest challenge I think for you would
be how do I get in front of my target
audience so if you're targeting
market is say you're targeting young
women young professional women as an
example then who else is selling to
these people that you can make some kind
of partnership with or either you have a
day where they all come in and you can
give out free samples or do a free
makeover for them basically you're
trying to find ways to get in front of
your target audience get them using it
and if they use it and they like it and
it's really helpful for them then
they're going to want to come back and
keep buying more from you so the biggest
challenge I think getting started for
you is making sure a you have a really
good product there's a lot of cosmetic
product out there so what's so special
about yours that makes it unique and
different from everything else and then
be finding low-cost ways or or free ways
to get in front of your target audience
and get them using it if you can do
those two things then you won't have to
worry about getting repeat customers
because they're going to keep coming
back to you they're going to tell their
friends and the business will take off
so hopefully you can sell those problems
and give us an update on how you're
doing so thanks for the question for
those of you watching if you like the
video please give it a thumbs up I
always love seeing those makes you want
to do more and if you have a question
about this video or a question about
your own company or challenge you're
facing please leave in the comment
section below I always read those I
always try to respond to everybody and
so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode